Brent Cavanaugh's accuser comes forward
a brutal murder in Israel and hurricane
Florence touches down I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
well this will be a fascinating show as
subterranean evils take place apparently
beneath our feet can actually feel the
floor vibrating because we are doing
construction here at the Daily wire
offices and that means more expansion
thanks to you our listeners but we'll be
discussing the actual news in just a
second a lot of news to get to first
let's talk about movement watches so
movement watches this stuff is just
fantastic look at this watch view this
do you see this right before you look
how clean and classic it looks look how
classy this thing is now did this thing
cost four hundred five hundred bucks no
this watch right here this cost like $99
right this thing cost beginning at $99
you can get a great watch over a
movement watches because they used to be
a bunch of crowdfunded kids working out
of a living room but in the past year
they've not only introduced a ton of new
watch collections for both men and women
they've also expanded sunglasses in
fashion for bracelets for her my wife
has the sunglasses she also has a
watchful movement my mom has a watchful
movement so does my father movement
watches are all about looking good and
keeping it simple they're not gonna keep
track of how many steps you take during
the day or how many calories you're
burning or anything like that they're
going to tell you the time and they're
gonna look classic and they're gonna
look good movement watches start at just
95 bucks at the department store you're
looking at 4 to 500 bucks movement
figured out that by selling online they
can cut out the middleman and that's how
they lower the prices get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro
that's MVM t.com slash up hero MVM t.com
slash shapiro movement watches it keeps
growing go check out movement right now
MV mt comm slash shapiro with 15% off
today free shipping free returns
alright so big news over the weekend is
that finally the accuser of Bret
Cavanaugh has come forward so as you
recall all the way back last week
Senator Dianne Feinstein in a last-ditch
attempt to stop the nomination of Brett
Kavanaugh decided to bring forward an
anonymous letter she did not actually
reveal the letters just said she had
such a letter that accused Brett
Kavanaugh president Trump's pick to
replace Justice Anthony Kennedy on the
Supreme Court it accused Brett Kavanaugh
of some unspecified offense so Dianne
Feinstein's original letter with regard
to all of this her original statement
with regard to all of this was this
quote I've received information from an
individual concerning the nomination of
Brett Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court an
individual strongly requested
confidentiality declined to come forward
or press the matter further and I have
honored that decision I have however
referred the matter to federal invest
of authorities and people like me said
um what the hell is that supposed to
mean I don't know who the lady is I
don't know what exactly the allegation
is I've know if checking this allegation
and so basically you're just saying now
here's an allegation I'm not gonna tell
you what it is that is supposed to
somehow end all of the all of the
hearings about Brett Kavanaugh and we're
supposed to just remove him from
consideration well now it turns out that
the woman in question has come forward
and she has leveled an allegation of
sexual assault against Brett Kavanaugh
from when he was 17 years old apparently
this is a letter as originally sent to
Dianne Feinstein July 30th 2018 so you
may begin by asking why exactly if
Dianne Feinstein had this since July
30th 2018 it should not bring it up at
Kavanagh's hearings that'd be a good
question
you might ask why I shouldn't refer to
the FBI earlier that would be a good
question you might ask why shouldn't
make it public earlier that would be a
good question you might ask why she
didn't show fellow Democrats the letter
that would be a good question none of
those questions would be answerable
because Dianne Feinstein did all of
those things she did not reveal it to
her Senate colleagues she did not reveal
it to the press she did not reveal it to
the FBI she did not ask Brett Kavanaugh
about it she waited until after
Kavanaugh had already testified and then
she came forward with this allegation
and then sort of dumped it into public
which looks like a dirty political smear
even if the allegations are true it
looks like a dirty political smear it
does call into question the seriousness
of the allegations when Dianne Feinstein
treated them so unserious Lee but here
is in fact the actual allegations in the
letter apparently this letter was
originally sent to a to a congresswoman
in California named a shoe Anna a shoe
from California she sent for his letter
on to Dianne Feinstein here is what the
letter said from July 30th 2018
dear senator Feinstein I'm writing with
information relevant in evaluating the
current nominee to the Supreme Court as
a constituent I expect that you will
maintain this as confidential until we
have further opportunity to speak Brett
Kavanaugh physically and sexually
assaulted me during high school in the
early 1980s he conducted these acts with
the assistance of redacted as what the
original letter said they redacted the
name the name it turns out according to
The New Yorker is a guy named Mark judge
who's also written for the Weekly
Standard and has become sort of a
respected conservative writer both were
once two years older than me and the
students at a local private high school
the assault occurred in a suburban
Maryland area home at the gathering that
included
and for others Cavanaugh physically
pushed me into a bedroom as I was headed
for a bathroom up a short stairwell from
the living room they locked the door and
played loud music precluding any
successful attempt to yell for help
Cavanaugh was on top of me while
laughing with judge who periodically
jumped onto Cavanaugh they both laughed
as Cavanaugh tried to disrobe me in
their highly inebriated state with
Cavanaugh's hand over my mouth I feared
he may inadvertently kill me from across
the room a very drunken judge said mixed
words to Cavanaugh ranging from go for
it to stop at one point when judge
jumped onto the bed the wait on me was
substantial the pile toppled and the two
scraps with each other after a few
attempts to get away I was able to take
this opportunity to get up and run
across to a hallway bathroom I locked
the bathroom door behind me both loudly
stumble down the stairwell at which
point other persons in the house were
talking with them I exited the bathroom
ran outside the house and went home I've
not knowingly seen Cavanaugh since the
assault I did see judge once at Blank
where he was extremely uncomfortable
seeing me I have received medical
treatment regarding the assault on July
6th I notified my local government
representative to ask them how to
proceed with sharing this information it
is upsetting to discuss sexual assault
and its repercussions and I felt guilty
and compelled as a citizen about the
idea I'm not saying anything I'm
available to speak fertil further should
you wish to discuss i'm currently blank
in conference blank ok so that is the
full text of the letter that dianne
feinstein had in her possession there
are several questions about this letter
first of all we don't know where this
actually happened right we don't
actually know where it happened cuz says
it was in suburban Maryland area home on
an unspecified date at an unspecified
time with unspecified others so what we
have here is a basic she said something
happened and then both guys who were
supposedly involved have denied that
anything like this ever happened so
Cavanaugh has released a pretty strong
statement saying I'm happy to come back
and testify anytime you want me to this
never happened absolutely mark judge
came 40 said this never happened and
that's not stopping Democrats from
saying that Cavanaugh's nomination
should be pulled again the real thing
that should happen here in reality if
Democrats are gonna take this seriously
the real thing that should happen here
is that the lady whose name is Christine
Blasi Ford and who's apparently a
professor at Palo Alto college she
should be called to testify in front of
the committee and then Cavanaugh should
be called to rebut her testimony right
if we're going to treat these
allegations of any level of seriousness
that's how this is supposed to go and
this is very
of how the Democrats played it with
Anita Hill they waited until the last
minute with Clarence Thomas's hearing
and they brought forward and he wouldn't
either he'll who allege that that
Justice Thomas had had sexually harassed
her the allegations were really really
shaky I'll go through in a second Feeney
to Hill allegations because I want to
show by comparison that these are even
more shaking than the Anita Hill
allegations but here is here is the
Washington Post talking about for to
afford now does an interview what with
the Washington Post she finally says
she's going to come forward speaking
publicly for the first time Ford said
that one summer in the early eighties
Kavanaugh and a friend both stumbling
drunk Ford alleges corralled her into a
bedroom during a gathering of teenagers
at a house in Montgomery County
well his friend watched Kavanaugh pinned
her to a bed on her back and groped her
over her clothes grinding his body
against hers and clumsily attempting to
pull off her one-piece bathing suit and
the clothing she wore over it when she
tried to scream she said he put his hand
over her mouth okay now number one let's
start with the allegation itself if that
allegation is true that's a pretty
horrible allegation okay that is an
allegation of actual sexual assault and
if you push a girl on a bed and you lie
on top of Vernie try to pull off her
clothes and cover your hand her mouth
with your hand while she's screaming
that's a bad allegation okay it's not
high jinks that's not you playing around
that's a bad allegation and that's an
allegation that if it can be
substantiated in any way would be
disqualifying from the Supreme Court and
frankly from the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals right I mean if that allegation
is true then he shouldn't be on the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals either but the
article continues and here's where it
starts to get dicey because she provides
no substantiating and no substantiating
evidence her story has changed over time
as you would imagine since a 36 year old
story the story is 2 years older than I
am as a human being and we're supposed
to now take it at face value let's just
be frank about the way the human memory
works in the first place human memory is
not a snapshot if I ask you about
something that happened when you were 15
chances are that it's going to change a
fair bit particularly if it's
emotionally invested it just is witness
testimony is not particularly good the
reason statutes of limitation exist in
the first place it is beyond the statute
of limitations presumably which is
presumably why the FBI didn't
investigate
also because there's no way for them to
investigate it the reason the statute of
limitations exists in the first place is
because it's an urge to people to come
forward with criminal behavior so we can
investigate it and convict people
on the basis of evidence otherwise this
is exactly what you end up with
unverifiable memories from a time that
is not even specified and then we're
supposed to simply jump to the
conclusion that it happened because a
woman said that it happened now again
maybe it happened I'm not saying the
woman made it up I don't know whether
she made it up I don't know that she's
miss remembering the incident I don't
know any of that stuff you don't know it
either the only person who knows any of
this stuff are the people who are in the
room two of whom deny that this ever
happened so Before we jump to every
thing that a woman says about something
that happened 40 years ago she suddenly
has keen snapshot memory it's very
interesting all the people who say that
we have to take at face value every
accusation from years and years and
years ago and all of its myriad details
details without any corroborating
evidence all those same people are the
same people who generally point out in
criminal trials that witness testimony
is quite unreliable and witnessed
estimate is witness testimony is is very
unreliable as a general rule and it's
gonna be even more unreliable when
you're talking about something that
happened to you in many cases and in
anyway the Washington Post continues
Ford's head shoes escaped able to escape
when Cavanaugh's friend and classmate at
Georgetown Preparatory School mark judge
jumped on top of them sending all three
tumbling she said she ran from the room
briefly locked herself in a bathroom now
here's where it gets dicey here's where
it gets really dicey for this particular
account maybe there's a way to
substantiate it maybe there's not the
problem is she hasn't actually given a
date as to when this happened so even if
Breck have nowhere to say listen I was
at summer camp that one that month but I
was out of town because she didn't give
a specific date that wouldn't help him
at all so how the hell is he supposed to
you know how is he supposed to maintain
his innocence when he doesn't even have
enough details to argue with the details
Ford said she told no one of the
incident in any detail until 2012 when
she was in couples therapy with her
husband this should raise red flag
number one okay so this thing originally
happened 36 years ago so now we're
saying she only even talked to her
therapist about it three decades later
this is very different from the Roy
Moore case for example in Roy Moore's
case there were several corroborating
details first of all the the women who
are accusing him named specific times in
places and it was corroborated that he
was in those places at those times too
there were multiple women three those
women gave contemporaneous statements so
they told their friends and family what
had happened at the time at the time
so when I was 15 years old I was abused
by members of my high school class
people knew that because there were
witnesses there and I told people at the
time here the witnesses all deny that it
happened and she told no one at the time
that it actually happened making her the
only person who can actually testify as
to the veracity of this actually
happening and she's gonna have to answer
some questions if we are going to if we
are going to come away with the
conclusion that Cavanaugh absolutely did
this and therefore should be
disqualified and we ruin his life as a
as an attempted rapist at age 17 we're
gonna talk a little bit more about this
first I want to tell you about
stamps.com so these days you can get
practically everything on demand our
podcast you can listen whenever you want
whatever it's convenient for you
there's no reason you shouldn't be able
to do that with all the great services
over at the post office well with stamps
comm you can you can access all those
great services right from your desk 24/7
when it's convenient for you
buying prints official US postage for
any letter any package using your own
computer and printer the mail carrier
picks it up just click print mail you're
done couldn't be easier we've used
stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices I use it at home as well it is
just fantastic it saves us time it saves
us money right now use promo code
Shapiro for this special offer 55 bucks
of free postage a digital scale and a
four week trial go to stamps calm before
you do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro again that stamps
comm and enter that promo code Shapiro
go check it out right now stamps comm
promo code Shapiro save time save money
don't wait in line at the post office
make sure that you are using your time
to its fullest by going to stamps comm
and get that special offer 55 bucks free
postage digital scale four-week trial
stamps calm once more click on the radio
mic at the top of the homepage and type
in at Shapiro okay so here's where it
gets spicy again Ford said she told no
one of the incident in any detail until
2012 when she was in couples therapy
with her husband the therapists notes
portions of which were provided by Ford
and reviewed by the washington post do
not mention Cavanaugh's name but say she
reported that she was attacked by
students from an elitist boys school who
went on to become highly respected in
high-ranking members of society in
Washington okay so first of all the
therapist notes don't actually include
Cavanaugh's name but her husband says
that you mentioned Cavanaugh's name now
I have heard from alleged rape victims
that very often therapists do not
include names in their therapists notes
I don't know if that's true or not I'll
assume that it's true for it for the
sake of argument and suggest that
that doesn't really you know cut against
her but the next part does the notes say
that for boys were involved okay well
that's a pretty major discrepancy so if
the notes say that for boys were
involved in her alleged rape and then
she says that her alleged attempted rape
and then she says that two boys were
involved how do you rectify that
discrepancy well she says that the
therapist just got it wrong that was an
error there are four boys at the party
but only two in the room notes from an
individual therapy session the following
year which presumably she has provided
since the therapist isn't I mean there's
client therapy and therapist privilege
and when she was being treated for what
she says have been long-term effects of
the incident show Ford described a rape
attempt in her late teens
hey there's discrepancy number 215 is
not late teens 15 is early teens and 15
is mid-teens at best is that your late
teens your late teens is when you're 19
your late teens they're 18 19 it's not
15 if somebody says to you a
fifteen-year-old
you wouldn't think late teens you'd
think that's a fifteen-year-old right
that's mid teen that's in many cases in
some cases prepubescent in an interview
her husband Russell Ford said that in
2012 session she recounted being trapped
in a room with two drunken boys one of
whom pinned her to a bed and molested
her and prevented her from screaming
he said he recalled his wife used
Cavanaugh's last name and voice
concerned that Cavanaugh might one day
be nominated to the Supreme Court
unclear exactly from his post account in
what context Cavanaugh's name was
mentioned so he said he recalled the
Cavanaugh's name was last Cavanaugh's
last name was used but did that mean he
was one of the four boys one of the two
boys the boy was on top of her not
cleared from the Washington Post account
so there are a bunch of questions to be
asked about all of this
Cavanaugh completely denies this stuff
he says I categorically and
unequivocally denied this allegation I
did not do this back in high school or
any other time judge says it's just
absolutely not I never saw Brett act
that way and he said that there was
there's no illegal activity at any time
I'm gonna give you more background on
this in just a second so here's the
story about Christine for Christine Ford
is a professor at Palo Alto University
she teaches in a consortium with
Stanford University training grad
students in clinical psychology her work
has been widely published in academic
journals which supposedly means now that
she's credible well again the
credibility of the statements is at
issue we'd have to take them seriously
no matter who gave them she contacted
the post through a tip line in early
July
when he become clear that Kavanagh is on
the short list of possible nominees to
replace Kennedy but before Trump
announced his name publicly a registered
Democrat who has made small
contributions to political organizations
she contacted her congresswoman around
the same time and then in late July she
sent a letter to Dianne Feinstein in the
letter before describe the incident and
said she expected her story to be kept
confidential
then she signed the letter as kristinb
lacy the name she uses professionally
the foreign accont acted the post she
declined to speak on the record for
weeks as she grappled with concerns
about what going public would mean for
her and her family and what she said was
her duty as a citizen to tell the story
so in other words she went to the
Washington Post she refused to go public
with the statement she refused to go on
the record with the statement and then
they basically ran with this Feinstein
found a way to leak this a couple of
days before the before the vote now here
is is the the questionable part why
bother telling the Washington Post about
this if you're not going to go public
with it unless you just want to smear
Cavanaugh now there's a possibility that
maybe what she wanted to do she the
listen I don't want to get involved but
I would love it if the reporters at the
Washington Post could track down what
actually happened here but obviously the
were the reporters at the Washington
Post could not track down what actually
happened here because they didn't run
with the story independently okay that
sort of stuff happens all the time by
the way that as a reporter as
journalists people come to you with
pitches and then you check out the
pitches sometimes they check out
sometimes they don't you take some
pitches you don't take others many of
the people who are involved in pitches
or self-interested actors you know that
all of that is just the way journalism
works but it's evident that if she came
to the post and the post couldn't track
anything further down they weren't gonna
run with it so instead they're running
solely on the basis of this vague
statement that she was now given and
then she tells the post that she engaged
Deborah Katz a Washington lawyer known
for her work on sexual harassment cases
on the advice of Katz he said she
believed four would be attacked as a
liar if she came forward four took a
polygraph administered by a former FBI
agent in early August the results
concluded four was being truthful when
she said a statement summarizing her
allegations was accurate okay well
that's that there are a few things to
point out here about polygraph first of
all polygraphs are inadmissible in
courts of law because polygraphs are
wildly wildly unusable Paul Drake Eames
who was an actual spy for the Russians
in the in the 1990s and 1980s Aldrich
Ames was that he actually passed a
polygraph test twice while he was
inactive
spy for the Russians so there's that
also the question that was asked on the
polygraph was whether a statement
summarizing her allegations was accurate
not whether the allegations themselves
were accurate so if I tell you a story
and the story is not true and then you
write down the story and then you ask me
whether the story that I just wrote down
reflects the story you told me that is a
different question than whether the
story you told me is true I could read
you a bedtime story about the Cat in the
Hat and then if you write that down and
then you say did I just write down the
story that you told your daughter at
bedtime I'd say yes does that mean that
this story of the Cat in the Hat is
factually true not really so it's
important to actually read what the
Washington Post report says by late
August Ford had decided not to come
forward calculating the two so would up
end her life and probably would not
affect Cavanaugh's confirmation why
suffer through annihilation if it's not
gonna matter she said well that's a
bunch of nonsense obviously this was
going to upend the entire process
everybody knew it
this bizarre notion that it was not
going to affect this in any way if she'd
come forward and evidence is just silly
her story leaked on Wednesday the
intercept reported Feinstein had the
letter and then Feinstein had not
released it to her colleagues and then
she released her statement the FBI
redacted the the state and the name from
the letter and then sent it to the White
House
The New York Times reported more details
on the incident then finally this woman
came forward and she says these are the
ills I was trying to avoid now I feel
like my civic responsibility is now
weighing my anguish and terror about
retaliation cat says she believed
Feinstein honored for his request to
keep her allegation confidential but
regrettably others did not which is
nonsense and again the letter was only
sent to three places presumably the
Washington Post Feinstein and and this
woman Anna Eshoo who's a representative
in California so I'm not seeing any of
that and then finally the Post report
concludes after so many years Ford says
she does not remember some key details
of the incident she believes it occurred
in the summer of 1982 when she was 15
around the end of her sophomore year
Kavanagh would have been 17 she says
that she knew them as friendly
acquaintances she says she doesn't
recall who owned the house how she got
to the house hey there's no way to walk
down these details even assuming that
she is telling the truth there is no way
to lock down these details and so we're
gonna have to hear more from her we're
gonna have to hear more from Cavanaugh
and there is no substantiating evidence
to
any of this because she didn't tell
anybody at the time the only person she
told us a therapist in 2012 okay now how
are people reacting to this I'll tell
you that in just one second first let's
talk about your life insurance so have
you gotten life insurance if you haven't
you're being an idiot you need life
insurance
everybody needs what it needs life
insurance because god forbid something
should happen to you you have to make
sure their family is being taken care of
September is national life insurance
Awareness Month
if you listen to the show you've heard
me talk about how important life
insurance is policy genius is the easy
way to get life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers find the best policy
for you and when you compare quotes you
save money it is indeed that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy they also
have emitter disability insurance and
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
so go to policy genius calm right now
get quotes apply in minutes rates are to
20 year low you can do the whole thing
on your phone right this minute
policy genius it is the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again
policies unions makes it easy to get the
right policy for you there's no reason
to procrastinate any longer the rates
are really good and everybody everybody
should have a life insurance policy go
check it out right now policy genius com
get those quotes apply in minutes policy
genius the best way to get life
insurance all right so Dianne Feinstein
naturally is doing what you knew she was
gonna do which is she is saying we
should now delay the actual vote so
Feinstein has said that she wants all of
this delicious as it has always been
mrs. Ford's decision whether to come
forward publicly for any woman sharing
an experience involving sexual assault
particularly when it involves a
politically connected man with influence
authoritative power is extraordinarily
difficult which by the way is why we
should encourage women to come forward
at the time it is very difficult to
assess guilt or innocence 36 years after
the event Cavanaugh did not have power
when he was 17 years old he was a
teenage boy she was a teenage girl okay
from the outset I believe these
allegations were extremely serious and
bear heavily on Cavanaugh's characters
is what Feinstein says well if that's
the case why didn't you ask him about
them why didn't you ask it he was right
there in front of you under oath why
didn't you ask him about them like
legitimately I don't understand the line
of reasoning these were so serious that
I hid them for months when my Senate
Democratic colleagues and then I
released them at the last minute without
any name
and now I want a new hearing well just
to clear his name we should give
Cavanaugh a new hearing just to clear
his name and just to get all the details
we should have four to come and talk to
the committee as well but it's the
Democrats are good at this at this game
they are very good with the last minute
dropping of the smear which I mean
frankly it looks like to me yeah again
maybe this is all true maybe it is but
the way Feinstein handles this makes it
look like a smear that's what it that's
just from any objective level
Feinstein's behavior is the most
questionable of anyone in this entire
situation she says she says I believe
these allegations were extremely serious
however as we've seen over the past few
days they also come in a price for the
victim I hope the attacks and shaming of
her will stop and this will be treated
with the seriousness it deserves
well fine theme did not treat it with
seriousness she hid it from her Senate
colleague she did not report it to the
FBI she did not report it to law
enforcement she didn't report it to the
White House she dint do any of those
things
she held it and she held it and she held
it and then she really said it last
minute and she expects the entire world
to turn on the time she says I support
mrs. Ford's decision to share her story
and now that she has it is in the hands
of the FBI to conduct an investigation
the FBI has already said how the hell
are we supposed to conduct an
investigation there's no specific
allegation about a specific time in
place what are we supposed to do okay it
may be beyond the statute of limitations
and we also don't know what the criminal
the federal crime here is this is
probably a state crime at best
and what what there was no
transportation across state line so I'm
not sure how this would be a man Act
issue so what exactly is the federal
what rises to the level of federal
criminality or what statute would be
implicated not even sure so this should
happen before the Senate moves forward
on this nominee Jeff Flake has come
forward he says we can't vote until we
hear more and the same thing is being
said by a bunch of other politicians
already so I am NOT I'm not sure what
the what the story here is Lindsey
Graham has issued a statement saying
that he will listen to any statement
Ford wishes to make he says if Ford
wishes to provide information to the
committee I would gladly listen to what
she has to say and compare that against
all the other information we've received
about Judge Cavanaugh he says if the
committee is to hear from Miss Ford it
should be done immediately so the
process can continue as scheduled and
then he says I agree with the concerns
expressed in the Judiciary Committee
statement about substance and process
regarding the allegations in this latest
claim against Judge Cavanaugh and
he said it was disturbing that these
uncorroborated allegations would surface
now and Senator Grassley's office truck
grassley on the Judiciary Committee he
says the same thing he issued a
statement we said it's disturbing these
uncorroborated allegations from more
than 35 years ago during high school
would surface on the eve of a committee
vote after Democrats sat on them since
July the franking member finds scene and
other Democratic Committee Democrats
took this claim seriously they should
have brought it to the full committees
attention much earlier well yes instead
they said nothing during to joint phone
calls with the nominee in August for
days of lengthy public hearings a closed
session for all committee members with
the nominee we're sensitive topics can
be discussed and in more than 13-hundred
written questions 65 senators met
individually with judge cabin answering
a nearly two month period before the
hearing began and yet this did this was
not brought up right yet Feinstein's
didn't try to share this with her
colleagues ahead of many of these
discussions it raised a lot of questions
about Democrats tactics and motives to
bring this to the rest of the
committee's attention well yes
and this is again reminiscent of the
Anita Hill situation which is now it has
now become gospel truth that Anita Hill
was sexually harassed by Clarence Thomas
and I made an HBO movie about it but
there's a bunch of evidence to suggest
that Clarence Thomas never harassed
Anita Hill so for example one witness
that Anita Hill called back during the
during the hearings there was a witness
who said she was told details about the
supposed sexual harassment while the two
were living in Washington but the
witness wasn't living in Washington when
Anita Hill worked for Clarence Thomas
Hill followed Clarence Thomas around
from job to job while supposedly he was
sexually harassing her she said she did
for job security but she was a federal
employee which is like the best job
security you could ever have
Hill made numerous opposing phone calls
to her supposed sexual harasser after
she stopped working for him so what what
you know Hill actually tonight she made
the call she initially denied she made
the calls but the calls were in the
phone logs
Hilla initially asked to be kept
anonymous this is why it's so
reminiscent Hill initially asked that
she would kept innominate anonymous
about these allegations in the same way
that this woman initially asked that she
be kept anonymous about the allegations
but if the allegations were actually
true just as in this case if the
allegations were actually true then why
would you care about being kept
anonymous because presumably the only
person in the room who knew
that you did it was the person was the
other person who's being accused so they
would know immediately who you were
talking about so what is the anonymity
matter now let's say that let's say that
in the Anita Hill situation Clarence
Thomas had been asked about there's a
woman in your office who accuses you of
sexually harassing her by talking about
pubic hair on coke cans right presumably
Clarence Thomas would know immediately
who's talking about and would have just
said oh you mean Anita Hill and she's a
liar right people would have known who
exactly was making the allegations
immediately the same thing would be true
here right if this woman says Brett
Kavanaugh sexually assaulted me when I
was fifteen we're in a house with four
other guys he tried to pull off my
bathing suit if Cavanaugh knew about
that he'd know exactly who it was and
presumably people would start digging
immediately so what's the point of the
anonymity if the allegations are gonna
be leveraged the only way this works is
if you make anonymous allegations that
are vague vague enough that they can't
hurt anyone hey he'll ID five times
about being told something from a
democratic status staffer she later
admitted to that under oath and a dozen
females who worked with Thomas and Hill
gave favorable testimony about Thomas
we've seen the same thing about
Cavanaugh so this looks a lot more like
a neat a hill than it looks like Roy
Moore looks a lot more like Annie to
hell than it does like Juanita Broderick
this is they're serious questions to be
asked about this tale and just taking it
at face value is not worthy of the
Senate Judiciary Committee so what I've
suggested is that four would be called
if she turns down the call they should
have a vote end of story because with
this information you can't turn down you
can't ruin everybody's life based on
this there's there's no way to do this
so it's there's like really I just don't
I don't know how you are supposed to
ruin a man's life based on an allegation
from nearly four decades ago that is
vague enough that there's no way to
refute it that's it we we cannot run our
country this way forget about judiciary
hearings we can't run our country this
way because legitimately any man can be
accused of anything at any time if we
run our country along the lines of these
allegations
I am the cleanest person in American
public life okay I am when it comes to
sexual matters there's no question I'm
the cleanest person in American public
life I was a virgin until I was married
the first woman I made a love to was my
wife like this is the only woman I've
ever made love to is my wife I'm
absolutely clean on this stuff there is
nothing to stop any woman I was alone
within a room when I was in law school
from coming forward and claiming
sexually assaulted her in some way
there's nothing to stop that hey and
then and what would I do to refute that
once the allegation has been made how do
you rebut it that that sort of question
does have to be asked when it comes to
manners is serious is this and the
higher people get in public life the
more likely that the stakes are high
enough that somebody could say something
that's untrue or it's possible that this
woman is misremembering the situation or
it's possible that in her own mind the
situation went one way and it didn't go
the other way I'm not even questioning
this woman's honesty all I'm suggesting
is that as an objective observer I need
observer I need more than this before I
say the Brett Cavanaugh should be run
off the Supreme Court on a rail and this
is not coming from somebody who's like
the biggest Brett Kavanaugh fan I didn't
think that this is I didn't think the
president from should have picked Brett
Kavanaugh as his first pick I was for a
me koni Barrett I mean it had been hard
to make a sexual allegation about a me
koni Barrett but with all that said is
this enough no it's not enough and we
cannot have this as the precedent for
killing judicial nominations or or this
will be there's no there is no bottom to
this ladder I mean it just keeps
descending if that's the case okay I
want to get to some other some other
news that happened over the weekend but
first let's talk about your internet
security whether you're in a cafe or
hotel you rely on public Wi-Fi to use
the internet on the go I do too but
something as simple as paying your bills
online from Starbucks could leave your
data exposed a hacker can easily
intercept your information stealing
passwords credit card numbers personal
details it's not just hackers either
government agencies like the NSA are
monitoring the entire internet possibly
scooping up your activity so what can
you do to defend yourself well the
software I use to protect my online
activity from spies and data thieves is
called expressvpn expressvpn has easy to
use apps they run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet expressvpn secures and anonymizes
my internet data by encrypting that data
in hiding my public IP address using
expressvpn I can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi without being snooped on having my
personal data stolen an express VPN cost
less than seven bucks a month and comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee so
you really have nothing to lose to take
back your internet privacy today find
out how I can get three months for free
go to expressvpn comm slash Ben that's
expr ESS VPN comm slash been for three
months free with a one-year package
again expressvpn secure your internet
now
that's expressvpn calm / Ben to learn
more go check it out right now okay so I
do want to get to an awful awful story
from Israel I want to get to Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez more and more frequently
I'm getting her name right and she
apparently is now cutting weird album
covers I'll explain what I mean in just
a second but first you're gonna have to
go over to Facebook and check us out
over there and coming up this Tuesday
September 18th 6:30 p.m. Eastern 3:30
p.m. Pacific you're not gonna want to
miss our next episode of daily wire
backstage with god-king jeremy boring
myself Andrew Klavan Michael Noel's
which is the worst as well as Alicia
Krauss plus we'll be joined by a special
guest Glenn Beck he's going to be by and
he's going to be talking about his new
book addicted to outrage plus there'll
be more will be we'll be taking
questions but only from daily wear
subscribers so make sure that you go
over there and you subscribe today again
that is Tuesday September 18th 6:30 p.m.
Eastern 3:30 p.m. Pacific join us for
daily we're backstage with special
guests Glenn Beck become a subscriber to
ask us your questions right now
subscriptions also come with the rest of
my show live there so Clavin show live
and the rest of Noel's show live if
that's something you're into because
you're some sort of weirdo $9.99 a month
gets you that plus the annual
subscription gets you this the very
greatest and beverage vessels leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr go check it
out
right now we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all right so meanwhile Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez has gotten herself in a little
bit of trouble why she got herself in a
little bit of trouble
well she's gotten herself in a little
bit of trouble because she doesn't know
how to answer basic questions about
things first she got herself in trouble
last week because for a socialist she
sure dresses like a non socialist so
these are a couple of pictures of
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez apparently from
her new album your money my fun and
here's a picture of her apparently she
also cut a wonderful wonderful number
she cut with the Village People
which is pretty great here she is
sitting on the stoop gazing into camera
ala John Lennon and she was wearing
apparently like $700 shoes and a $2,700
outfit so this whole outfit cost
something like $3,500 so she has a good
little socialist spending other people's
money she's and so how did she respond
to the allegations that she is buying
very very expensive things
she's the alt-right doesn't even seem to
understand the concept of magazine
shoots no we get it and we're not also
not the all right not everyone on the
right who criticizes you as a socialist
for spending thirty five hundred dollars
on an outfit not all of those people are
alright also we understand the concept
of magazine shoots you don't seem to
understand the concept of a magazine
shoot which would actually be about you
putting your best foot forward as a
Democratic Socialist because you don't
get to keep the clothes duh
which is weird she says I don't pretend
to fight for a living wage and Medicare
for all I do it yeah yeah mm-hmm and
then she says get used to me slaying
Luke's le wks because I am an excellent
thrift shopper I don't know what a luke
is or why you would kill it is this a
thing like maybe I'm out of touch with
the with the children I am a de mi have
touch with the younger generation
already I'm only 34 years old am I
already out of touch with the people who
are who are 17 years old I mean how old
is this woman this woman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez I think she's like 28
right so she's of my generation I wasn't
aware the people my generation said
ridiculous things like slaying Luke's I
don't know what I don't know what it is
to slay a Luke like the only person I
know who tried to slay a Luke was kylo
Ren and even he failed it is very
difficult to slay Luke solder I don't
know what that is slaying Luke's le w
slang singly oh okay so I've been
informed it's coming in right now fast
I've been informed by Alex Zangaro our
producer who all only has the most
up-to-date information that a Luke is a
really nice outfit I don't know how Alex
knows that I'm gonna have to ask him
some questions later about his level of
knowledge on on these matters but I will
admit that I don't know the hell she's
talking about or why she is dressed like
a member of a of an alt rock indie band
in a magazine so there's that but that
was of course not the worst thing that
she did over the weekend she also was
asked specific questions by Jake Tapper
CNN Jake asked her like some actual
serious questions like you're going to
spend a crapload of money where is all
this crap load of money going to come
from and she basically said well it is a
crap load of money so it's gonna come
from the but because she has no actual
answer from where the money is going to
come from and so it sounded like this so
where's the other 38 trillion dollars
going to come from well one of the
things that we need to realize when we
look at something like Medicare for all
Medicare for all would save the American
people a very large amount of money and
what we see as well is that these
systems are not just pie in the sky they
are many of them are accomplished by
every modern civilized democracy in the
Western world it is a an externality if
you will of a unprecedent I've been
precedented amounts of student loan debt
I'm assuming I'm not going to get an
answer for the other 38 trillion dollars
but so slow clap for Jake right there I
mean this is why I still love me some
Jake Tapper and on more than one
occasion that pretty pretty spectacular
stuff I mean just so I soon we're not
gonna get any sort of answer on like
where all this came from so yeah that's
right you're not gonna get in the answer
on where all this came from because it's
all pie-in-the-sky nonsense that you
throw out there for the for the rubes
who who eat this stuff up and pretend
that spending 38 trillion dollars is no
big deal and that we can all just come
up with this money no matter what
there's a reason that socialist
democratic countries are starting to
move toward the right they're having to
embrace either austerity or immigration
restrictions or there or they're just
kicking the can down the road but none
of this is going to end well for
countries that blow out the budget the
way that we are and by the way that's
not unique to Democrats Republicans are
blowing out the budget
exactly the same way Democrats would be
accepted Democrats actually gained
control they're gonna pass a bunch of
mandatory spending that's gonna make all
of the debts and deficits we have right
now look like child's play okay well
meanwhile this is an awful story from
the land of Israel
a man named ari Fuld was murdered over
the weekend ari Fuld was an activist he
lived in a fraught which is a quote
unquote settlement what people need to
know about the settlements is that this
is traditional land of Israel is the
Jews have every right to settle in these
places and the city of efrat is I mean
sleep Everly Hills it's over it's a
really nice area
ari Fuld has spent an awful lot of time
covering the media particularly media
bias in in this particular area of
Israel he came into Los Angeles not all
that long ago we were supposed to do a
meeting and it just sort of fell through
but he was stabbed to death over the
weekend he's a father of four Leora sure
cuz a friend of the victim told the told
a news agency that Ari was like his name
implied it means lion in Hebrew he was
very involved in explaining and
defending the good reputation of the
State of Israel on the internet and
before the citizens of the world he was
about to launch a new hospira site to
reveal the truth about Israel in English
he was a good friend who knew you would
stand behind who you knew would stand by
you and protect you in any situation a
lowly terrorist came up behind him in a
cowardly way stabbed him Ari was one of
the fighters in the efrat Emergency
Squad we didn't expect anything less of
him even after he was wounded re-engaged
with the terrorists and chased him as he
was bleeding and managed to respond and
shoot at the terrorists he actually
wounded the terrorists and stopped him
from attacking other folks the video
looks like this for folks who can watch
you can actually see in the corner of
the screen re full the standing there
and then he is attacked from behind by a
by a terrorist and then he's wounded I
mean he he died of these wounds and he
is chasing the terrorists down and he
and he shoots the terrorists and the
terrorists and the terrorist is is
wounded but does not die full then
collapses because he has been stabbed in
the back and he would later die of his
wounds there is an actual GoFundMe that
is up for re-entry do the same I'm not
sure if tax deductible I don't know the
answer to that but you should check it
out anyway his kids have been left
without pretty much anything and
obviously he has four of them so
absolutely terrible story and
a solid reminder that these are the
folks that Israel is dealing with the
this man's family the this is the
attackers family seventeen-year-old the
attackers family will be given some sort
of reward by the Palestinian Authority
he will given be hit they will be given
a monetary reward for stabbing an
innocent Jew like re full just a
terrible terrible story his brother also
relayed a message about about you know
who he was just just too awful but not
unpredictable there's a really bad ways
an American citizen there's a reason
that the there's a reason that the Trump
administration has been withdrawing all
of its support from the Palestinian
Authority the Palestine Liberation
Organization it's because they support
stuff like this and they're exactly
right to do so now speaking of the Trump
administration over the weekend the
hurricane touched down now the hurricane
has claimed several lives already
there's a one-year-old that was swept
away after her mother lost her grip
people didn't get they're always some
people don't get out of the way of these
hurricanes or unable to get out of the
way of these hurricanes the death toll
and the evacuations are indeed rising as
of this hour the woman to North Carolina
has been entirely cut off by floodwaters
from the tropical depression Florence so
all of this is bad stuff the media of
course are incessantly covering the the
way that the Trump administration is
handling it because they're looking for
any sort of opening and they of course
are very interested to demonstrate that
the president doesn't care about the
victims of hurricanes so they're more
than happy to have on the the FEMA head
guy names is Chris lon I'm trying to
member his his brock long and he's in
the administrator of FEMA he defended
President Trump on Sunday over the
dispute over the death toll in Puerto
Rico this is why it was so foolish for
the president to have said anything
about the death toll in Puerto Rico
because now we get to fight this on
national TV which doesn't look good here
was FEMA's brock long trying to defend
President Trump on the death toll in
Puerto Rico you know look these studies
are all over the place the Harvard study
was done differently studies a different
period of time versus the George
Washington study there's a big
discrepancy whether it's directness or
indirect deaths yeah I don't know who
they interviewed with him I agency they
may have looked at a funeral benefits to
help you know calculate whatever number
and and that's a number you know that
that's the only number that we would
really be able to contribute to any
study going forward okay well what he's
saying here is not false and I talked
about all of this last week the
variability of studies from the deaths
and in natural disasters it's difficult
to come up with a hard number but the
fact that this is an argument that the
Trump administration is having at a time
when all focus should be on you know
actually saving people they can walk and
chew gum at the same time for sure but
public focus should be on helping folks
it's it's just silly for the Trump
administration to do that again
once again the Trump administration on
policy very often does the right thing
and on rhetoric they very often undercut
themselves and that's that's a really
unfortunate thing that that I wish they
would avoid okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like Yom Kippur is coming
up on Tuesday night that is the Day of
Atonement so I will be out Wednesday of
this week who's filling in for me on
radio I believe that is drew so Andrew
Clavin will be filling in for me on
radio but in any case I'm you know I'll
be in in shul diving and praying and
over the over the last holiday over over
Rosh Hashanah I was able to jump into a
book that I've been meaning to get to
for a long time it's a book called the
prime ministers by Buddha Avner if you
are interested in sort of the history of
the State of Israel at all if you're
interested in the inside story about all
the controversial decisions made
basically between 1947 and 1983-84 the
Lebanon War then you should check it out
the prime ministers by Yehuda Avner it's
a really quick read and it's it's really
exciting and they all the he's certainly
aventure served under four different
prime ministers levy Eshcol Golda Meir
Yitzhak ravine and Menachem beggin
beggin really is sort of the heart of
the book because beggin was by far the
most imposing prime minister in Israeli
history and he was also a foundational
figure in Israel's formation I get a lot
of questions about books you should read
about Israel this is definitely a new
one that I've read that it's that's on
the list so go check it out the Prime
Minister's but you had Avner okay a
couple of things that I like real fast I
do love it when Democrats simply come
out with what they actually think of the
American people and Joe Biden is doing
it now so Joe Biden came out over the
weekend and he suggested that President
Trump supporters are the dregs of
humanity which is if you're looking to
win an election I'm not sure how this is
helpful particularly but go for it man
this time
they not you have an ally in the White
House this time they have an ally there
are small percentage of the American
people virulent people some of them the
dregs of society okay so and some of
them are and again he's unspecified
these dregs of society but insulting the
voting base always goes well so Hillary
Clinton learned that when she called
everybody deplorable Barack Obama called
everybody bitter clinger as an alienated
half the country now Joe Biden is
calling people the dregs of sight don't
don't forget he is the best of what
American politics has to offer we've
been told there was a new Concilium sin
American politics between the left and
the right we sought a John McCain's
funeral when Joe Biden was the voice of
a new wonderful politics where we all
shared in what we believed mm-hmm yeah
that was all crap and we all knew that
it was nonsense at the time okay time
for a couple of things that I hate so
Anne Hathaway who I think in the in the
dictionary under white privilege there's
actually a picture of Anne Hathaway Anne
Hathaway has now come out and denounced
white privilege while accepting an award
because this is what we have to do now
is virtue signal along every line she
ripped into white privilege at the at
this same event that Joe Biden spoke at
this national equality dinner the Human
Rights Campaign national dinner Human
Rights Campaign is a pretty extreme left
group and she and you know when I say
they're an extreme left group I mean
that they have relationships with the
Southern Poverty Law Center and they're
constantly accusing people who are not
actually homophobic of being homophobic
in any case Anne Hathaway felt the
necessity to talk about how everybody
who is not gay black Hispanic a woman
all these people aren't actually
privileged in American society here's
what it sounded like it is important to
acknowledge that with the exception of
being a cisgender male everything about
how I was born has put me at the current
center of a damaging and widely accepted
myth that myth is that gayness orbits
around straightness transgender orbits
around cisgender
and that all races orbit around
whiteness this
is wrong I don't know what in the world
this means I didn't realize that we were
actually in space and gravitating around
one another like planets drawn to larger
bodies I'm I don't understand what this
means and then she says that when she
that when she spent time with the LGBTQ
community her older brother is gay she
learned to reject the myth I appreciate
this community because together we are
not just going to question this myth we
are going to destroy it let's tear this
world apart and build a better one tear
this world apart and build a better one
is a pretty good Democratic slogan
because honestly it's what they believe
never mind that this is the world that
actually built the foundations for gay
rights never mind that that what built
the foundation for individual rights is
in fact the judeo-christian tradition
because those rights don't exist nearly
anywhere else on earth
let's we're all going to pretend now I
suppose that the West is the worst place
in the world for gays and what we really
have to do is tear down the entire
system in order to make the world safe
for gay people
even though America is safe for gay
people and well well and I say that as a
Jew right America is safe for Jews -
they're more hate crimes against Jews
than against gays on a per capita basis
I believe so according to FBI statistics
so again this is all at least they're in
there close to on par this is this is
all wildly overstated but it wins her
points with that with the brownie base
that she needs she needs a group of
people who are going to brown-nose her
no matter what she does because this is
what stars need these days and it
doesn't matter that she's yeah that when
I say brownie base that's what I mean
and that's what she that's what she is
looking for so is everybody else in
Hollywood which is why they are interned
brown-nosing everybody on the on the
left in terms of the social justice
warrior crap okay here is Federalist
paper so we'll do a Federalist paper
this week we're all the way up to
Federalist number 45 James Madison talks
about the constitutional plan he
specifically talks about the balance
between the federal government and the
states and it gets in some really
interesting territory he argues that the
convention was for there to promote
human happiness basically one of the big
issues with the Constitutional
Convention is that originally it was
called in order to change the Articles
of Confederation not completely supplant
them was something new he has to make
the case that it's okay to just scrap
them and do something new and the case
that he makes a pretty broad one and not
a very good one actually he says we're
the plan of the Convention adverse to
the public happiness my voice would be
reject the plan or the Union itself
inconsistent with the public happiness
it would be abolished
Union he says but if the Union has been
as has been shown be essential to the
security of the people of America
against foreign danger if it be
essential to their security against
contentions in wars among different
states if it be essential to guard them
against those violence and oppressive
factions which embittered the blessings
of liberty if an award the Union be
essential to the happiness of the people
of America is it not preposterous to
urge as an objection to a government
without which the objects of the Union
cannot be attained that such a
government may derogate from the
importance of the governments of the
individual states in other words he says
human happiness requires us to override
the rights of the states again this is a
bad legal case it's a bad legal okay
it's a good emotional case a bad legal
case and it's a case that would actually
in some ways lead to the the the tariff
of abominations the Civil War a lot of
the divisions between state and federal
government that culminate in the
bloodiest war in American history
Madison still argues that the states
still have a lot of power under the
Federal Constitution and this I think is
important to note because most of these
state powers have now dissipated he says
the state governments may be regarded as
constituents and essential parts of the
federal government whilst the latter is
nowise essential to the operational
organization of the former in other
words in other words the states run on
their own the feds only the states he
says without the intervention of the
state legislatures the president of the
United States cannot be elected at all
right that is the Electoral College so
it was specifically put there in order
to give the states inordinate power as
opposed to the direct population and now
there's obviously calls to scrap the
electoral college
he says they must in all cases have a
great share in his appointment and well
perhaps in most cases of themselves
determinate and the Senate will be
elected absolutely and exclusively by
the state legislatures it used to be
that senators were appointed by their
state legislators no longer now they are
appointed by direct vote I think it's a
bad amendment and it's had a bad effect
of basically turning all of our
politicians into populist even the House
of Representatives though drawn
immediately from the people will be
chosen very much under the influence of
that class of men whose influence over
the people obtains for themselves in
election into the state legislatures in
order in other words people will start
with state assemblies and then they'll
run for Congress that used to be more
true it is not quite as true anymore
state power has waned and for some good
reasons it has waned but it has not
overall been an unmitigated good it's
it's just I think you know the original
balance from between the feds in the
States has been abrogated in pretty
difficut ways that has some costs okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest news I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing